[موسيقى]
تغير كل شيء في حياتهم
فلا عمل ولا معين
وحدها المساعدات تبقيهم على قيد الامل
والانتظار هو الوجه الاخر لكوريا الجنوبيه
تقدم البلد وساءت احوال مسنه
مشهد مثل هذا ليس نادرا في العاصمه في
الخامسه والثمانين ما زالت صامدانغ تنوء
بفقل احوالها الماديه الصعبه
تقضي يومها في جمع علب الكرتون لبيعها
لمخازن تعيد استعمالها
وكما هو متوقع لا تجني الكثير لكن لا خيار
هذه المره دولار هو مبلغ صغير جدا لكن ليس
لدي حل اخر انا مضطره الى العمل وانا في
الخامسه
ليست وحدها في ذلك من اجل الدولارين يشقى
وكثير ممن جاوزوا الثمانين طوال اليوم
حين اعمل عشره ايام احصل على عشرين دولارا
تقريبا عمري 83 افضل العمل على ان ابقى
عاطل
لكن هذا العمل على شقائه لا يكفي كثيرون
يضطرون الى الاصطفاف امام طوابير
المساعدات معظمهم لم يكونوا اغنياء قبل
تقاعدهم لكنهم لم يكونوا بحاجه الى من
يمنحهم الطعام
كثير من هؤلاء لم يعيشوا الفقر قبل
التقاعدهم هم في وضع صعب لان ما يتلقونه
المعاشات ضعيف جدا نحاول المساعده لكن
الوضع صعب
يزيد من صعوبه الوضع ان المسنين يشكلون
خمس السكان والنسبه في ارتفاع مستمر في
مجتمع من لا ينتج فيه يجد نفسه على الهامش
لا مفاجاه ان البلد يسجل واحده من اعلى
نسب الانتحار في العالم حتى غدا هذا الجسر
يسمى جسر الموت لكثره منع القوا بانفسهم
منه الى النار
اجتماعيا تفرض القيم التقليديه في كوريا
الاحترام والتقدير لمن كان اكبر سنا
اقتصاديا يمنح النموذج الراسمالي لمكانه
والاعتبار لمن كان اكثر انتاجا في صراع
النموذجين ووجد كبار السن انفسهم على هامش
المجتمع ما دامت الغلبه بحسابات الاقتصاد
محمد البقالي الجزيره سول كوريا الجنوبيه